Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Nature knows no political frontiers. She begins by establishing life on this globe and then watches the free play of forces. Those who show the greatest courage and industry are the children nearest to her heart and they will be granted the sovereign right of existence. Nobody can doubt that this world will one day be the scene of dreadful struggles for existence on the part of mankind. In the end, the instinct of self-preservation alone will triumph. Before its consuming fire,
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。自然界不认识政治疆界。她首先在这个星球上建立生命，然后观察各种力量的自由博弈。那些展现出最大勇气和勤奋的人，是她心中最亲近的孩子，他们将被赋予生存的主权。没有人会怀疑，这个世界终有一天会成为人类生存斗争的惨烈现场。最终，唯有自我保存的本能会获胜。在它那吞噬一切的火焰面前，
this so-called humanitarianism, which connotes only a mixture of fatuous timidity and self-conceit, will melt away as under the March sunshine. Man has become great through perpetual struggle. In perpetual peace, his greatness must decline. That was Adolf Hitler writing in 1925 in Mein Kampf, My Struggle. And Dominic, I have not put on a comic Austro-German accent because in a way this is too sombre, I think, for such flummery. I guess so, Tom. Because really this is the passage that sums up what Hitler is all about. The idea that man is born for competition and that unless he is embroiled in competition,
这种所谓的“人道主义”——它只意味着愚蠢的胆怯和自负的混合物——将像在三月的阳光下一样融化。人类通过永恒的斗争变得伟大。在永恒的和平中，人类的伟大必然衰落。这是阿道夫·希特勒 1925 年在《我的奋斗》（Mein Kampf）中所写的内容。多米尼克，我没有模仿那种滑稽的奥德口音，因为我觉得这太沉重了，不适合那种轻浮的表演。我想也是，汤姆。因为这确实是概括希特勒核心思想的段落。即人类生来就是为了竞争，除非他卷入竞争，
he will diminish and fade. And this is what governs Hitler's attitude to the purpose of Germany, that he has become the leader of Germany above all to bring Germany triumph in war. Is that an exaggeration to say that? No, I think it's absolutely right. And I think you did absolutely the right thing by the way and immediately translating mein kampf into my struggle because we always call it mein kampf we actually miss it's like with lebensraum or the fuhrer or any of these other words that we leave in german we actually miss what they mean and the idea of struggle of conflict is at the very heart of hitler's sense of and the world, isn't it? The most searing experience of his life was serving in the trenches in the Great War, and then the experience of defeat.
否则他就会萎缩和消亡。这正是希特勒对德国使命的态度，他成为德国的领袖，首要目的就是带领德国在战争中取得胜利。这样说算夸张吗？不，我认为这完全正确。顺便说一句，你刚才直接把《Mein Kampf》翻译成《我的奋斗》做得非常对，因为我们总是称它为《Mein Kampf》，实际上忽略了它的含义。就像我们保留“生存空间”（Lebensraum）或“元首”（Fuhrer）这些德语词汇一样，我们实际上错过了它们的本意。而斗争、冲突的理念，正是希特勒对自身和世界认知的核心，不是吗？他一生中最刻骨铭心的经历，就是在第一次世界大战的战壕中服役，以及随后的战败体验。
He believes, he has imbibed that idea that was so common in the 1880s and 1890s that comes out of the kind of social Darwinism of the day, that mankind is doomed to this life of conflict and war and actually doomed is the wrong word maybe isn't it because he thinks the only true nobility and meaning comes through through struggle through conflict and through defeating others but also it's not just mankind is it it's the different races of mankind that they are locked in a perpetual struggle. And that if, for instance, the Aryans, the German people do not triumph, then they will be conquered and defeated and disappear. As had seemed likely to happen in 1918, 1919. So for Hitler, you conquer or you die. So this is an existential struggle for him.
他相信，他吸收了 19 世纪 80 年代和 90 年代非常流行的那种社会达尔文主义思想，即人类注定要过这种充满冲突和战争的生活。其实“注定”这个词可能不对，因为他认为唯有通过斗争、冲突和击败他人，才能获得真正的崇高和意义。而且这不仅仅是针对人类，而是人类的不同种族，他们被锁在永恒的斗争中。如果，比如说，雅利安人、德国人民不取得胜利，那么他们就会被征服、被击败并消失。正如 1918 年、1919 年看起来极有可能发生的那样。所以对希特勒来说，要么征服，要么死亡。因此，对他而言，这是一场生存斗争。
Absolutely it is. Absolutely. And Hitler, lots of people come to power all through history, planning wars. I mean, it's, you know, Alexander the Great was planning a war against the Persians, but Hitler is unusual in that his war is not a way of just getting prestige. It's not a strategic imperative. It's not a way of winning political support. I mean, it is all those things, but it's something more. War is absolutely at the essence of his project and constant war, I think. It's an ideology. It's an ideology, exactly.
绝对是。绝对是。历史上有很多领导人上台后都在策划战争。亚历山大大帝也曾策划过针对波斯人的战争，但希特勒的不同之处在于，他的战争不仅仅是为了获取声望。这不是一种战略上的迫切需要，也不是为了赢得政治支持的手段。虽然这些因素都有，但它更深层。战争绝对是他计划的核心，而且是持续不断的战争。这是一种意识形态。没错，这正是一种意识形态。
So when the Nazis come to power in 1933, is Hitler planning war from that point? And if so, I mean, how is he dealing with the army who presumably again have to be the means by which he launches on his wars? It's a good question. So Hitler, it's very obvious to anybody who's studied Hitler's writings and his speeches that he is planning a war. So in May 1928, he had said, you know, my priority will be to lead our people into bloody action that's five years before he takes power um but he's sort of downplayed that in the early 1930s when he was slightly rebranding the nazis as a populist party of social protest because obviously if you say to people i'm going to lead this into a bloody conflagration a lot of people would say no not for me thanks right but
那么，当纳粹在 1933 年上台时，希特勒从那时起就开始策划战争了吗？如果是这样，他如何处理军队？因为军队理应是他发动战争的工具。这是一个好问题。所以，对于任何研究过希特勒著作和演讲的人来说，他正在策划战争是非常明显的。早在 1928 年 5 月，他就说过，我的首要任务将是带领我们的人民进行血腥的行动——那是在他掌权前五年。但在 20 世纪 30 年代初，他稍微淡化了这一点，当时他将纳粹重新包装成一个社会抗议的民粹主义政党。因为很明显，如果你告诉人们“我要带领你们进入一场血腥的浩劫”，很多人会说“不，谢谢，我不感兴趣”，对吧？但是
but if he's saying uh i am going to reverse the humiliating limitations that have been placed on Germany by the Versailles Treaty, then that's very different, isn't it? Yes. So Hitler comes to power at the end of January 1933. And one of the first things he does on the 3rd of February is he goes to meet the army chiefs, the generals, the head of the army, Wernher von Blumberg, who is his defense minister, his war minister. And Hitler says to the army, who many of them are quite suspicious of him, he's only a corporal, remember, and they are conservative and they're nationalists, but a lot of them are not Nazis. And he says to them, listen, my priorities are sort of A, to deal with Germany's internal
但如果他说“我要扭转《凡尔赛条约》强加给德国的屈辱限制”，那情况就完全不同了，不是吗？是的。希特勒于 1933 年 1 月底上台。他做的第一件事之一，就是在 2 月 3 日去会见军队首脑、将军们，以及国防部长、战争部长维尔纳·冯·勃洛姆堡。希特勒对军队说——他们中的许多人对他相当怀疑，毕竟他只是个下士，而且他们是保守派和民族主义者，但很多人并不是纳粹——他对他们说，听着，我的首要任务是：第一，处理德国内部的
enemies, to crush Marxism. That's brilliant as far as they're concerned. They don't like Marxism. And secondly, he says, in the long run, we're going to want to expand. We're going to want to build up the army. And we're going to want to have some living space in the East, Lebensraum. That idea, that word, Lebensraum, living space, is very current in the early 1930s. It's not just the Nazis who used that word. And again, they are delighted by this. They're like, brilliant. Those are our ambitions. They are burning with resentment. They believe they've been stabbed in the back in 1918. They think they were humiliated in the
敌人，粉碎马克思主义。这对他们来说太棒了。他们不喜欢马克思主义。其次，他说，从长远来看，我们要扩张。我们要扩充军队。我们要向东方寻求一些生存空间（Lebensraum）。“生存空间”这个词在 20 世纪 30 年代初非常流行。不仅仅是纳粹在使用这个词。同样，他们对此感到欣喜若狂。他们觉得，太棒了。这些正是我们的抱负。他们心中燃烧着怨恨。他们认为自己在 1918 年被背后捅了一刀。他们认为自己在
Treaty of Versailles and very poorly treated. They want to build up their army again. They want to recapture some of the territory that Germany lost. In those ambitions, they're probably no different from the military elite of any other country that would have lost the First World War. So actually, they think, great, I don't necessarily love Hitler, but his ambitions tally with my own. And how much popular support is there for this? Well, I think loads of popular support. So I think that idea of having more living space, of expanding to the East, is very popular with business elites, for example. I mean, they look at something like Poland, Czechoslovakia and so on. They say, this should be our backyard.
《凡尔赛条约》中受到了羞辱和极不公正的对待。他们想重建军队。他们想夺回德国失去的一些领土。在这些抱负上，他们可能与任何其他在第一次世界大战中战败国家的军事精英没有什么不同。所以他们想，太好了，我不一定喜欢希特勒，但他的抱负与我的一致。那么这有多少民众支持呢？嗯，我认为有大量的民众支持。所以我认为，拥有更多生存空间、向东方扩张的想法，例如在商业精英中非常受欢迎。他们看着波兰、捷克斯洛伐克等地，说，这应该是我们的后院。
But what do they think is going to happen to the Poles or the Czechs? How does that work, do they think? Well, don't forget, most of these... We know what Hitler thinks, but... Yeah, but most of these people had lived in the Second Reich, in the Kaiser's empire, and that had loads of poles and so on in it. I mean, it's not unthinkable to them. So that's what they think is going to happen. They imagine it as being like the Bismarckian Reich. Yeah, that's a good way of putting it.
但他们认为波兰人或捷克人会怎样？他们认为这会如何运作？别忘了，大多数这些人……我们知道希特勒是怎么想的，但是……是的，但大多数这些人生活在第二帝国，即德皇的帝国中，那里有很多波兰人等等。这对他们来说并非不可想象。所以这就是他们认为会发生的事情。他们将其想象成俾斯麦时期的帝国。是的，这样说很贴切。
I mean, some of them are more extreme, of course. Some of them are more radical, but not all of them. A lot of them are monarchists or were monarchists. A lot of them think, great, let's bring back the world of 1880s, 1890s Germany, you know, big power in Europe. Okay, subject peoples, empire, economic expansion. Spikes on helmets, all that spikes on helmets you know sockets the french all that sort of thing and that's not just it's not so it's not just the conservatives and business elites it's loads of ordinary germans so if you're an apolitical german and you've lived through the nightmare of the first world war the early 1920s the revolution and so on weimar inflation great depression all that stuff the idea of being great again the idea of actually recapturing your lost
当然，他们中有些人更极端。有些人更激进，但并非全部。他们中许多人是君主主义者，或者曾经是。他们很多人想，太好了，让我们恢复 1880 年代、1890 年代的德国世界，你知道，欧洲的大国。好吧，臣民、帝国、经济扩张。头盔上的尖刺，所有那些头盔上的尖刺，你知道，法国人的插座，所有这些东西。而且这不仅仅是保守派和商业精英，还有大量的普通德国人。所以，如果你是一个非政治化的德国人，经历过第一次世界大战、20 世纪 20 年代初的革命、魏玛通胀、大萧条等等的噩梦，那么“再次伟大”的想法，真正夺回你失去的
virility and credibility and self-respect and all of that stuff, as far as you're concerned, what's not to like? This all sounds great. And if Hitler, this vulgar guy, is the vehicle for that, brilliant. So there are two massive problems though, facing anyone who wants a policy of military expansion. And the first is that there are internationally agreed limitations on Germany's ability to expand its armed forces. I mean, they are written into international treaties that Germany has signed. But the other one is the fact that Germany is skint. And as Cicero famously said, the sinews of war are having lots of cash, basically. So if you don't have money, you can, as Cicero famously said, the sinews of war are having lots of cash, basically.
男子气概、信誉和自尊等等的想法，对你来说，有什么理由不喜欢呢？这听起来都很棒。如果希特勒这个粗俗的家伙是实现这一目标的工具，那太棒了。然而，任何想要推行军事扩张政策的人都面临两个巨大的问题。第一个是国际上对德国扩军有明确的限制。这些限制写在德国签署的国际条约中。另一个问题是德国没钱了。正如西塞罗那句名言所说，战争的命脉基本上就是拥有大量的现金。所以如果你没有钱，正如西塞罗那句名言所说，战争的命脉基本上就是拥有大量的现金。
So if you don't have money, you can't rearm. But those two things are interlinked to some degree. So rearmament against the principle of the treaties. I mean, almost everybody in Germany who is not, you know, firmly on the left thinks that will happen in the long run. They think we were forced to sign these treaties, which they were, and in the long run, whether by diplomacy or just by a series of coup de main, we will reassert our right to have an army. And that will obviously be very useful for us with reinvigorating the economy. But Dominic, sorry to do it, but Dominic, but just to say, well, it'll be fine, they'll just rearm. I mean, there is a very obvious problem, which is that the whole of the West of Germany,
所以如果你没有钱，你就无法重整军备。但这两件事在某种程度上是相互关联的。所以，违反条约原则进行重整军备。几乎所有德国非左翼人士都认为，从长远来看，这会发生。他们认为我们是被迫签署这些条约的，确实如此。从长远来看，无论是通过外交手段还是通过一系列突袭，我们都会重申我们拥有军队的权利。这显然对我们重振经济非常有用。但是多米尼克，抱歉打断你，但多米尼克，只是说“没关系，他们会重整军备的”，这有一个非常明显的问题，那就是德国的整个西部，
basically in the Rhineland, has been demilitarized. And that means that the French could just march in and seize the Ruhr, which is Germany's industrial heartland, which they've already done once. Yeah, in the 20s. seize the Ruhr, which is Germany's industrial heartland, which they've already done once. Yeah, in the 20s. You know, that's a dangerous problem for the German high command to negotiate, isn't it? Exactly. They're playing a massively dangerous game. You're absolutely right. So on the one hand, they've got a small army. They're limited under treaty to just 100,000 men, far smaller than the army of France. And second is, you under the treaty of versailles and then the treaty of locarno they have demilitarized the rhinelands that's the region all along germany's western
基本上就是莱茵兰，已经被非军事化了。这意味着法国人可以直接开进并占领鲁尔区，那是德国的工业心脏地带，他们已经做过一次了。是的，在 20 年代。占领鲁尔区，那是德国的工业心脏地带，他们已经做过一次了。是的，在 20 年代。你知道，这对德国最高统帅部来说是一个危险的谈判难题，不是吗？正是如此。他们正在玩一场极其危险的游戏。你说得完全正确。所以一方面，他们只有一支小规模的军队。根据条约，他们被限制在仅 10 万人，远小于法国军队。第二，根据《凡尔赛条约》和后来的《洛迦诺公约》，他们将莱茵兰非军事化了，那是德国西部边境沿线的所有地区。
border and effectively that just means the french can walk in there's no german troops there to stop them by law the german is not allowed to have troops there to stop them the french can swan in as you say just capture germany's industrial base so hill is in a he's in quite a weak position at the beginning he's got a couple of things in his favor first of all there is a massive domestic constituency for rearmament not just because it means regaining your pride but it also won't bring a big economic boost one of his first cabinet meetings he actually says everything has to be about rearmament. All the spending, they're having a big argument about a dam in Silesia.
实际上，这意味着法国人可以走进去，那里没有德国军队阻止他们。根据法律，德国不允许在那里驻军。法国人可以像你说的，直接大摇大摆地占领德国的工业基地。所以希特勒在开始时处于相当弱势的地位。他有几件事对他有利：首先，国内有巨大的重整军备的选民基础，这不仅意味着重获尊严，还会带来巨大的经济提振。在他的一次内阁会议上，他实际上说一切都必须围绕重整军备。所有的支出，他们当时还在为西里西亚的一个水坝争论不休。
And he says, listen, everything must be, you know, these things are interlinked. So reinvigorating the domestic economy, we can do that through rearming. So the autobahns, for example, Tom, the motorways, he regards them as great military arteries. He's thinking about having them covered and tanks rolling along them and stuff. I mean, actually, it doesn't really work out that way. And there's lots of people who are delighted by this. I was amazed by this because I had vaguely thought that the German economy recovers
他说，听着，一切都必须……你知道，这些事情是相互关联的。所以重振国内经济，我们可以通过重整军备来实现。例如，高速公路（Autobahns），汤姆，他把它们视为伟大的军事动脉。他考虑过把它们覆盖起来，让坦克在上面行驶之类的。其实，事情并没有那样发展。而且有很多人对此感到欣喜若狂。我对此感到惊讶，因为我模糊地认为德国经济复苏
because Hitler is basically pursuing Keynesian policies. In other words, he's paying people to do things, like the New Deal in the United States at the same time. And I'd always thought that the Autobahns were the kind of poster boys for this policy, but apparently not true at all. So I was reading Adam Tooze's great book, The Wages of Destruction, about the German economy. And he says that they were never principally concerned as work creation measures, and they didn't contribute at all, really, to the relief of unemployment, which came as complete news to me. They're purely done for
是因为希特勒基本上在推行凯恩斯主义政策。换句话说，他付钱让人做事，就像同时期美国的“新政”一样。我一直认为高速公路是这项政策的招牌，但显然根本不是这样。所以我读了亚当·图兹（Adam Tooze）关于德国经济的伟大著作《毁灭的代价》（The Wages of Destruction）。他说，它们从来没有被主要视为创造就业的措施，而且它们实际上根本没有对缓解失业做出贡献，这对我来说是全新的消息。它们纯粹是为了
military purposes, basically, are they? Yeah. Everything in Hitler's mind is, if there's not a military purpose to it, if it's not making Germany fitter, healthier, stronger, more prepared for war then it's kind of pointless i think that's his that's his approach just sticking to the autobahns because it relates to the military is actually again which came as a surprise to me although it shouldn't have done because my brother's always going on about it how backward the german economy is so one of the issues with the autobahns is that Germany just doesn't really have any kind of domestic cars. So again, Adam Tooze has some amazing stats. In 1935,
军事目的而建的，基本上是这样，对吗？是的。在希特勒的心中，如果一件事没有军事目的，如果它不能让德国更健康、更强壮、为战争做更充分的准备，那么它就是毫无意义的。我认为这就是他的方法。坚持说高速公路与军事有关，这再次让我感到惊讶，尽管本不该如此，因为我哥哥总是唠叨德国经济是多么落后。所以高速公路的问题之一是德国根本没有任何种类的国产汽车。所以，亚当·图兹有一些惊人的统计数据。1935 年，
US vehicle ownership was 20.5% of the population. In Britain, it was 4.5%. In Ireland, it was 1.8%. And in Germany, 1.6%. Because now we think of Germany as the home of the motor industry. But there's no kind of economic base in that sense. So how are the Nazis getting Germany into a position where people are starting to feel richer? And how are they able then to translate that into the process of rearming? Or is it kind of interfused? Well, they are interfused. The Germans are adopting, I suppose, what you would say. rearming or is it kind of interfused well they're there they are interfused um the germans are
美国汽车拥有量占人口的 20.5%。英国是 4.5%。爱尔兰是 1.8%。而德国是 1.6%。因为现在我们认为德国是汽车工业的故乡。但在那种意义上，根本没有经济基础。那么纳粹是如何让德国进入人们开始感到富裕的状态的呢？他们又是如何将其转化为重整军备的过程的呢？还是说它们是融合在一起的？嗯，它们是融合在一起的。德国人正在采用，我想你会说……重整军备，还是说它们是融合在一起的？嗯，它们是融合在一起的。德国人正在
adopting i suppose what you would say i mean if one were being very sort of simplistic you'd say a kind of keynesian approach in that they are spending an awful lot of money they are trying to have everything at once they're throwing money at the economy in terms of building stuff and building factories putting people to work in rearming. That's what they're doing. And they are sort of trying to ride two horses at once because at the same time, Germany is an economy that is dependent on imports, particularly imported foods. And raw materials. And raw materials.
采用，我想你会说……如果一个人说得非常简单，你会说这是一种凯恩斯主义的方法，因为他们正在花费大量的金钱。他们试图同时拥有一切。他们在建设和工厂方面向经济投入资金，让人们在重整军备中工作。这就是他们正在做的事情。他们试图同时骑两匹马，因为与此同时，德国是一个依赖进口的经济体，特别是进口食品。还有原材料。还有原材料。
They don't have enough raw materials. So actually from the very beginning, the economic approach they take is predicated on war. The aim is that they will plunder. Yeah. That they'll get the raw materials by conquering neighboring countries. The model they adopt, which is to sort of go for this crash rearmament program,
他们没有足够的原材料。所以实际上从一开始，他们采取的经济方针就是以战争为前提的。目标是他们将进行掠夺。是的。他们将通过征服邻国来获得原材料。他们采用的模式，即进行这种崩溃式的重整军备计划，
it will not work. The wheels will completely fall off and you'll have colossal inflation and shortages on the shelves and not enough food and all of this, unless you can somehow acquire loads of new territory and loads of new raw materials. So in other words, they deliberately pick an economic approach that makes war inevitable. That's obviously the argument of Adam Tooze and other historians, Richard Evans and so on.
是行不通的。车轮会完全脱落，你会面临巨大的通货膨胀、货架短缺、食物不足等等，除非你能以某种方式获得大量的新领土和大量的新原材料。换句话说，他们故意选择了一种使战争不可避免的经济方针。这显然是亚当·图兹和其他历史学家，如理查德·埃文斯（Richard Evans）等人的观点。
So for Hitler, there's an ideological dimension. We need to conquer because the race demands it, the impulse of the blood demands it. But also there's an economic one that we're going to borrow loads of money to invest in tanks and Stukas and whatever. And then we don't have to worry about that debt because we're just going to use our tanks and Stukas to grab the money and the raw materials that will then enable us to pay it back. They are speculating to accumulate, I suppose you might say, Tom. And what they're trying to accumulate is other people's countries. Yes. Now, just to go back to the point you made a while ago,
所以对希特勒来说，有一个意识形态的维度。我们需要征服，因为种族需要它，血液的冲动需要它。但也有一个经济维度，即我们将借入大量资金投资于坦克、斯图卡轰炸机等等。然后我们不必担心那笔债务，因为我们将利用我们的坦克和斯图卡轰炸机去抢夺资金和原材料，这将使我们能够偿还债务。我想你可以说，他们是在投机以积累，汤姆。而他们试图积累的是别人的国家。是的。现在，回到你刚才提到的那一点，
which is about Hitler's weakness and so on, and how on earth is he going to do this, he does have one thing in his favor, which is the Allies, who in the 1920s had been very hardline towards Germany, have over time become much less hardline. And actually, by the time Hitler comes to power, there are an awful lot of people, especially in somewhere like Britain, who think, do you know what? The Germans have been pretty hard done by. The First World War, now I think about it,
关于希特勒的弱点等等，以及他到底要怎么做，他确实有一件事对他有利，那就是盟国。在 20 世纪 20 年代，盟国对德国非常强硬，但随着时间的推移，他们变得温和多了。实际上，当希特勒上台时，有很多人，特别是在英国这样的地方，他们想：你知道吗？德国人确实受到了相当不公正的对待。第一次世界大战，现在回想起来，
it was a terrible tragedy and a mistake. And the terms at the end, I understand why we imposed harsh terms, but they were harsh. The Germans aren't such bad chaps, really. And obviously, we can't force them to live like dogs forever. At some point, we will have to readmit them on equal terms. I mean, Germany is a big place. They were proud people. And Hitler is brilliant. He is, I mean, he has many, many terrible qualities.
那是一场可怕的悲剧和错误。最后的条款，我理解我们为什么要强加严厉的条款，但它们确实太严厉了。德国人其实并不是那么坏的家伙。显然，我们不能强迫他们永远像狗一样生活。在某个时候，我们将不得不以平等的条件重新接纳他们。我的意思是，德国是一个大国。他们是自豪的人民。而希特勒很聪明。他，我的意思是，他有很多很多可怕的品质。
He's lazy. He doesn't read stuff. That's not the worst quality. Yeah. But as an executive. As a leader. Yeah. As a leader.
他很懒。他不读书。那不是最糟糕的品质。是的。但作为一名执行者。作为一名领袖。是的。作为一名领袖。
But he is an astonishingly good opportunist. He's brilliant at seeing the weaknesses in other people's position and exploiting them. He can just sniff it out, can't he? Sniff it out. And this is what he does with the Allies. He knows that the British are not that bothered about what's going on on the continent. He knows that there are a lot of people in France who don't want another war, who hate the thought of repeating the slaughter. And he is determined to exploit that and to
但他是一个令人惊讶的好机会主义者。他非常擅长发现别人立场中的弱点并加以利用。他能嗅出来，不是吗？嗅出来。这就是他对盟国所做的事情。他知道英国人并不太在意欧洲大陆上发生的事情。他知道法国有很多人不想再打仗，他们讨厌重复那场屠杀的想法。他决心利用这一点，并
exploit the guilt that people feel. And of course, lots of people feel he has legitimate grievances. Right. And that passage of Mein Kampf that we read at the beginning, where he sniffs at the humanitarian impulse, he is exploiting the humanitarian impulses in, say, the British and French popular opinion. He absolutely is. He sees them. He gets reports on them. He sees it as weakness. He does see it as weakness. In every way. Yeah.
利用人们感到的内疚感。当然，很多人觉得他有合理的申诉。没错。而我们开头读到的那段《我的奋斗》，他嘲笑人道主义冲动，他正在利用英国和法国公众舆论中的人道主义冲动。他绝对是在利用。他看到了它们。他收到了关于它们的报告。他将其视为软弱。他确实将其视为软弱。在各个方面。是的。
Yes. So from the start, the interesting thing about this is he proceeds slowly and carefully with a series of calculated gambles and one by one they work. I don't know whether the analogy is building bricks or toppling dominoes, but whichever metaphor you choose, I guess the first one is his decision to walk out of the disarmament talks that are under the aegis of the League of Nations that are happening in Geneva. They've been going on for a while, but they haven't really got anywhere
是的。所以从一开始，这件事有趣的地方在于，他通过一系列经过计算的赌博，缓慢而谨慎地推进，一个接一个地成功了。我不知道是用“砌砖”还是“推倒多米诺骨牌”来比喻，但无论你选择哪种隐喻，我想第一个是他在日内瓦国际联盟主持下的裁军谈判中退出的决定。这些谈判已经进行了很长一段时间，但并没有真正取得任何进展，
because the French in particular are not terribly keen on disarming. And in October 1933, this is the first of a series of coups, great coups, PR triumphs. Hitler says, I'm going to pull out of the Geneva conference under Sarming because why should Germany when we're so weak compared with everybody else anyway? And what's more, the League of Nations is just, I mean, it's basically a conference of the victors.
因为法国人尤其对裁军不太热心。1933 年 10 月，这是他一系列政变中的第一次，伟大的政变，公关胜利。希特勒说，我要退出日内瓦裁军会议，因为既然我们与其他人相比已经如此虚弱，德国为什么要裁军呢？而且更重要的是，国际联盟基本上只是一个胜利者的会议。
It's humiliated us. You know, no one takes us seriously. The League of Nations has never sort of been just to us. We're walking out of the League of Nations. It's hard to think of anything more calculated to provoke Hitler's contempt than a disarmament process at the League of Nations. Yeah, that's true. I mean, he hates it. And the League of Nations kind of internationalist talking shop that he regards, you know, with utter disdain. But of course, he's still playing the victim card,
它羞辱了我们。你知道，没有人认真对待我们。国际联盟从来没有公正地对待我们。我们要退出国际联盟。很难想到有什么比国际联盟的裁军进程更能激起希特勒的蔑视了。是的，那是真的。我的意思是，他讨厌它。国际联盟那种国际主义的清谈馆，他以极度的蔑视看待它。但当然，他仍然在打受害者牌，
isn't he? That's the irony of it. That's the fiendish cunning of it, is that he's not condemning the League of Nations as a Nazi. He's condemning it because it is Victor's justice. Exactly, Tom. Yeah, that's absolutely right. So when ordinary Germans hear this, many of them are absolutely delighted. They're like, yeah, we're always being pushed around and humiliated. Finally, someone has the guts to say, sod you. They're like, yeah, we're always being pushed around and humiliated. Finally, someone has the guts to say, so do you. We're not going to sit here and just be sort of made fun of and belittled. The League of Nations has done nothing for us.
不是吗？这就是它的讽刺之处。这就是它邪恶的狡猾之处，他不是以纳粹的身份谴责国际联盟。他谴责它是因为它是“胜利者的正义”。正是如此，汤姆。是的，这完全正确。所以当普通德国人听到这个消息时，许多人感到欣喜若狂。他们想，是的，我们总是被欺负和羞辱。终于有人有胆量说“去你的”。他们想，是的，我们总是被欺负和羞辱。终于有人有胆量说“去你的”。我们不会坐在这里被嘲笑和贬低。国际联盟对我们毫无作为。
What are we wasting our time with it for? There's a pattern that starts now, which is that Hitler will have a great foreign relations coup, and then he will call an election at the Reichstag. The Nazis are pretty much the only party, so it's not really much of an election. Or a plebiscite or something. He loves a plebiscite. Nobody enjoys plebiscites more than Adolf Hitler. He'll have a plebiscite and says, what do you think of my latest idea? And he gets, once again, 95% approval in the plebiscite, 92% victory in the Reichstag so-called election. And everybody's sort of, well, what a tremendous business. And of course, loads of nationalists. Indeed, you don't even have to be a fervent
我们为什么要浪费时间在它上面？从现在开始出现了一种模式，即希特勒会进行一次伟大的外交政变，然后他会在国会（Reichstag）举行选举。纳粹几乎是唯一的政党，所以这算不上什么选举。或者全民公投之类的。他喜欢全民公投。没有人比阿道夫·希特勒更喜欢全民公投了。他会举行一次公投，说，你们觉得我的最新想法怎么样？然后他再次在公投中获得 95% 的支持率，在所谓的国会选举中获得 92% 的胜利。每个人都觉得，哇，真是了不起。当然，大量的民族主义者。事实上，你甚至不需要是一个狂热的
nationalist. You could just be a sort of slightly conservative patriot. And you could say, finally, someone's told the French where to get off. Brilliant. Now, in 1934, the following year, he does two things, one of which is very smart. And the other one is a sign of the danger of overreaching. So the very smart thing is he's still as you said at the beginning really quite weak the french could walk in at any moment and they're also worried about the polls on the other side so hitler does something that many of our listeners may find grimly ironic he signs a non-aggression treaty with the polls 10 year non-aggression treaty and And what year is this? 1934. Yeah, January 1934. Due to run out in 1944. Yes. I wonder if he'll stick to it. Well, exactly.
民族主义者。你可能只是一个稍微保守的爱国者。你可以说，终于有人告诉法国人该滚到哪里去了。太棒了。现在，在 1934 年，即第二年，他做了两件事，其中一件非常聪明。另一件事是过度扩张的危险信号。所以非常聪明的事情是，他仍然像你在开头所说的那样，确实相当虚弱。法国人随时可能开进，而且他们也担心另一边的波兰人。所以希特勒做了一件我们的听众可能觉得极其讽刺的事情：他与波兰人签署了一份互不侵犯条约，为期 10 年的互不侵犯条约。这是哪一年？1934 年。是的，1934 年 1 月。预定于 1944 年到期。是的。我想知道他是否会遵守它。嗯，正是如此。
And the Poles think, brilliant, we've secured our Western border. Europe is shocked because the Poles are meant to be allies with the French. The French have been trying to build this sort of ring around Germany, and Hitler has broken it by signing this deal with the Poles. And that means that Hitler now is free from the fear of being encircled. He's not going to be attacked on two flanks by the French and from Eastern Europe. The other thing that he does, which is a sign of the dangers of overreaching, an illustration of the risks in his foreign policy, and we'll talk much more about this in the next episode. He sort of semi-tries to orchestrate a coup in Austria. So Austria, obviously German speaking, his homeland,
波兰人想，太棒了，我们确保了我们的西部边境。欧洲感到震惊，因为波兰人本应是法国人的盟友。法国人一直试图在德国周围建立这种包围圈，而希特勒通过与波兰人签署这项协议打破了它。这意味着希特勒现在摆脱了被包围的恐惧。他不会在两个侧翼受到法国人和东欧人的攻击。他做的另一件事，是过度扩张危险的信号，是他外交政策中风险的例证，我们将在下一集中详细讨论。他半心半意地试图在奥地利策划政变。所以奥地利，显然是讲德语的，他的祖国，
place where he was born, his dream is to reunite it with the Reich. And a load of Austrian Nazis assassinate the chancellor of Austria, a guy called Dolfus. Again, we'll talk more about this next time. And it doesn't go well. The Italians under Mussolini say they sort of move an army to the border, don't interfere with Austria. And Hitler basically has to back down. And it's very embarrassing for him. And it's a reminder at this stage, he's been in for what, just over a year? It's a reminder of how weak he is and it's a sign that actually if his neighbors do stand up to him he can be forced to back down it's very embarrassing because also there's a night of long knives and all that kind of going on at the same time isn't there so he's not secure yeah and in fact at the end of that year 1934 he's still not totally secure
他出生的地方，他的梦想是将其与帝国重新统一。一群奥地利纳粹暗杀了奥地利总理，一个叫多尔夫斯（Dolfus）的人。同样，我们下次会详细讨论。结果并不顺利。墨索里尼领导下的意大利人说，他们把军队调到了边境，不要干涉奥地利。希特勒基本上不得不退缩。这对他来说非常尴尬。这提醒人们，在现阶段，他上台才一年多？这提醒人们他是多么虚弱，这是一个信号，如果他的邻国确实站出来反对他，他可以被迫退缩。这非常尴尬，因为同时还有“长刀之夜”之类的事件在发生，不是吗？所以他并不稳固。是的，事实上，在 1934 年年底，他仍然不完全稳固。
the army by the way so there's another little burst of tension, even after the Knights of the Long Knives. At the end of 1934, the army is sort of displeased about the SS who are being armed and stuff. They're still a bit sore about the stormtroopers, the SA. And there's a bizarre meeting they have at the beginning of 1935 where Hitler talks, as he so often does. He's got a kind of Fidel Castro-esque appetite for long speeches. He talks for 90 minutes and then starts crying during the speech.
顺便说一句，军队方面，即使在“长刀之夜”之后，仍然有一点紧张。1934 年底，军队对正在武装的党卫军（SS）感到不满。他们对冲锋队（SA）仍然有点怨气。他们在 1935 年初举行了一次奇怪的会议，希特勒像往常一样发表讲话。他有一种类似菲德尔·卡斯特罗式的对长篇演讲的胃口。他讲了 90 分钟，然后在演讲中开始哭泣。
Yes, the whole kind of theatrical, the master showman. Yeah, begging for the loyalty of the generals. And the generals say, okay, fair enough. You know, we'll, yeah, stop crying. Stop crying, exactly. Dry your eyes, mate. And the funny thing with Hitler is that whenever he's in trouble at this point, luck just plays completely into his hands because his luck would have it under the sort of timetable, which he doesn't control. There's a region called the Saarland in the far west of Germany, which is a sort of, it's a big, what is it? Co mining aren't coal and iron territory and since the end of this first world war under the treaty of versailles it has been put under the formal control of the league
是的，那种戏剧性的表演，大师级的表演者。是的，乞求将军们的忠诚。将军们说，好吧，公平地说。你知道，我们会……是的，别哭了。别哭了，正是如此。擦干眼泪吧，伙计。希特勒有趣的地方在于，每当他在这一点上遇到麻烦时，运气总是完全站在他这一边，因为他的运气取决于他无法控制的时间表。在德国最西部有一个叫萨尔区（Saarland）的地区，它是一个很大的……是什么？煤矿，煤炭和铁矿领土。自第一次世界大战结束以来，根据《凡尔赛条约》，它一直处于国际联盟的正式控制之下，
of nations and the french have had a right to the zaland's economic resources now you can absolutely see if you're even a remotely patriotic german yeah i'm not happy about that this is like such a standing affront i mean it's such a sort of weeping sore now after 15 years the deal was that the half a million people of the czar land could have a yet another plebiscite on whether or not they would go back to germany or whether they would join the french of course they were always going to go back to germany But the Nazis pour tons and tons of resources into the referendum campaign. They make loads of effort to win over their very Catholic voters in the Saarland. And Catholics are sometimes, they're a bit iffy about Hitler. But the local Catholic hierarchy are persuaded to back Hitler and the Nazis and the idea of reunification with germany so it is in january
法国人拥有萨尔区的经济资源权。现在，即使你是一个稍微爱国的德国人，你绝对可以理解，我不高兴，这简直是一种持续的侮辱，我的意思是，这就像一个流脓的伤口。现在 15 年后，协议是萨尔区的 50 万人可以进行另一次公投，决定他们是回到德国还是加入法国。当然，他们总是会回到德国。但纳粹在公投运动中投入了大量的资源。他们做了大量的努力来争取萨尔区非常天主教的选民。天主教徒有时对希特勒有点怀疑。但当地的天主教高层被说服支持希特勒和纳粹，以及与德国统一的想法。所以是在 1 月
1935 91 of the zahlan's electorate vote to join the german dictatorship rather than the french democracy and again a great boost for hitler a great little a little nice little coup to show that he is you know he is making germany great. But the bigger thing, which is on his mind all this time, is building up the army. So the army, as I said, was about 100,000 men, much smaller than the French army. The army, at the beginning of March 1935, a guy called General Beck, Ludwig Beck,
1935 年，91% 的萨尔区选民投票加入德国独裁政权，而不是法国民主政权。这再次对希特勒来说是一个巨大的提振，一个不错的小政变，表明他正在让德国变得伟大。但更重要的事情，一直在他脑海中的，是扩充军队。所以军队，正如我所说，大约有 10 万人，比法国军队小得多。军队，在 1935 年 3 月初，一个叫贝克将军（General Beck），路德维希·贝克（Ludwig Beck）的人，
later was involved in the Stauffenberg plot in the 1940s, 1944, Operation Valkyrie, but anyway, that's by the by. Beck prepares a big memo and he says, ideally, we would like an army of 23 divisions, which would be about 300,000 men. And they're limited to 100,000. Yes, under the Treaty of Versailles.
后来参与了 1940 年代、1944 年的施陶芬贝格阴谋，“瓦尔基里行动”（Operation Valkyrie），但无论如何，那是题外话。贝克准备了一份大备忘录，他说，理想情况下，我们想要一支 23 个师的军队，大约 30 万人。而他们被限制在 10 万人。是的，根据《凡尔赛条约》。
So here again, you've got a very good example, I think, Tom, of how even if that person is not Adolf Hitler, this is probably going to happen at some point. So had the most likely alternative to Hitler happened, which is a kind of nationalist general as a dictator of Germany in the 1930s, he would have probably done a similar kind of thing, tried to expand the army and basically said, sod you to the Treaty of Versailles. But Hitler goes about doing this
所以在这里，汤姆，你又得到了一个非常好的例子，说明即使那个人不是阿道夫·希特勒，这种情况也可能会在某个时候发生。如果希特勒最可能的替代者发生了，即 20 世纪 30 年代德国的一位民族主义将军作为独裁者，他可能也会做类似的事情，试图扩充军队，基本上对《凡尔赛条约》说“去你的”。但希特勒这样做的方式
in a very sort of characteristically Hitlerian way. you know he's he's heard all this he knows that he would have to bring back conscription to build up the army and he knows the french and the british would be appalled by this and on the 13th of march he's called his his adjutant who's a guy called lieutenant colonel hosbach to his um to a hotel everything happens in hotels in this story i mean hitler is that the amount of kind of work that's going on at hotel receptions. So this is why Wes Anderson needs to do his biopic on Hitler. Absolutely. So Hitler's staying in this hotel in Munich and this adjutant turns up. The guy arrives and Hitler, of course, is still in bed because he's so lazy. So Hitler gets up just before midday and says to the adjutant, I think we should increase the army. I'm persuaded even now. How many people do you think they should and says to the Adjutant, I think we should increase the army. I'm persuaded of it now.
以一种非常典型的希特勒式的方式。你知道，他听到了这一切，他知道他必须恢复征兵制来扩充军队，他知道法国人和英国人会对此感到震惊。3 月 13 日，他把他的副官，一个叫霍斯巴赫（Hosbach）中校的人叫到他的……酒店。这个故事里的一切都发生在酒店里。我的意思是，希特勒在酒店前台所做的工作量。这就是为什么韦斯·安德森（Wes Anderson）需要拍摄他的传记片。绝对是。所以希特勒住在慕尼黑的这家酒店里，副官出现了。那个人到了，希特勒当然还在床上，因为他太懒了。所以希特勒在中午前起床，对副官说，我认为我们应该扩充军队。我现在甚至被说服了。你认为他们应该……并对副官说，我认为我们应该扩充军队。我现在被说服了。
How many people do you think they should have? And the Adjutant says, I don't know, 36 divisions, which is more than half a million men, far bigger than even the army themselves wanted. And Hitler says, brilliant, yeah, let's do it. Go for it. And on Saturday, the 16th of March, he announces it. He says, we're going to have a new army, 36 divisions.
你认为他们应该有多少人？副官说，我不知道，36 个师，也就是超过 50 万人，比军队自己想要的还要多得多。希特勒说，太棒了，是的，让我们做吧。去做吧。在 3 月 16 日星期六，他宣布了这一消息。他说，我们将拥有一支新军队，36 个师。
Without consulting with the generals. The generals, when they hear this, are absolutely, they can't believe it. This is far more than they had, because they think this will undoubtedly inflame the allies. You know, this is such a slap in the face to them. And what happens? The Italian ambassador apparently went kind of white with anger. The French ambassador sort of started huffing and puffing and shrugging his shoulders and expostulating.
没有咨询将军们。将军们听到这个消息时，绝对……他们简直不敢相信。这比他们拥有的多得多，因为他们认为这无疑会激怒盟国。你知道，这对他们来说是一个巨大的耳光。结果发生了什么？意大利大使显然气得脸色发白。法国大使开始气喘吁吁，耸耸肩，表示抗议。
The British guy reacted with kind of phlegmatic indifference. Sans foi. Yeah, sans foi. Very British. He said, what about your air force and your fleet? Do you still have similar plans for those? You know, he kind of didn't bat an eyelid. Well, it's always the fleet for the British, isn't it?
英国人以一种冷漠的态度做出了反应。没有信仰（Sans foi）。是的，没有信仰。非常英国人。他说，你的空军和舰队怎么样？你对那些还有类似的计划吗？你知道，他甚至连眼皮都没眨一下。嗯，对英国人来说，永远是舰队的问题，不是吗？
It is. And in Germany, the reaction is utter, utter, utter euphoria. What always happens with Hitler's coups is at first people are kind of, oh no, the French are going to attack us. Yeah. And then when it becomes obvious after day one, the French are going to do nothing at all. Huge crowds assemble, people cheering and shouting.
确实。而在德国，反应是彻底的、彻底的、彻底的狂喜。希特勒的政变总是发生这样的情况：起初人们有点“哦不，法国人要攻击我们了”。是的。然后当第一天过后，很明显法国人什么都不会做时，巨大的人群聚集起来，人们欢呼雀跃。
They're waving flags and stuff. The next day, they have a big parade. It becomes a public holiday called Heroes Memorial Day. They're playing Beethoven. The war minister, General Blomberg, he comes out and he gives a speech. He says, the world has been made to realize Germany did not die of its defeat in the world war. Germany will take the place she deserves among the nations. Richard Evans, like a lot of historians, quotes a really interesting diary by a Hamburg housewife called Louisa Solmitz,
他们挥舞着旗帜之类的。第二天，他们举行了盛大的游行。这变成了一个公共假日，叫“英雄纪念日”。他们播放贝多芬的音乐。战争部长勃洛姆堡将军出来发表了演讲。他说，世界已经意识到德国并没有死于世界大战的失败。德国将在各国中占据她应得的位置。理查德·埃文斯像许多历史学家一样，引用了一位名叫路易莎·索尔米茨（Louisa Solmitz）的汉堡家庭主妇的非常有趣的日记，
because she is a kind of small C conservative nationalist Hamburg housewife whose husband is of Jewish descent. Yeah. And so their child has not been given Aryan status, right? Exactly. So there's a kind of ambivalence about the Nazis. And yet she could not be more ecstatic all over it. When she heard the announcement, she says, I rose to my feet. It overcame me the moment was too great i had to listen standing the day that we had longed for since the disgrace of 1918 we would never have experienced versailles if such actions had always been taken and such
因为她是一个小 C 保守派民族主义汉堡家庭主妇，她的丈夫有犹太血统。是的。所以他们的孩子没有获得雅利安身份，对吧？正是如此。所以对纳粹有一种矛盾心理。然而，她对此感到无比狂喜。当她听到这个消息时，她说，我站了起来。它征服了我，那一刻太伟大了，我不得不站着听。我们从 1918 年的耻辱以来一直渴望的那一天。如果一直采取这样的行动，我们永远不会经历凡尔赛，而且这样的
answers always given and the the spd who have been exiled the social democrats they have agents who are writing reports. They're brilliant sources on public opinion in Germany. And there's just one report, enthusiasm on the 17th of March, enormous. The whole of Munich was on its feet. People can be compelled to sing, but they can't be forced to sing with such enthusiasm. The trust in the political talents and will of Hitler becomes greater all the time. Hitler is loved by many. So another of Hitler's gambles has worked.
答案总是给出的，那些被流放的社会民主党人，他们有特工在撰写报告。他们是了解德国公众舆论的绝佳消息来源。有一份报告写道，3月17日的热情非常高涨。整个慕尼黑都沸腾了。人们可以被迫唱歌，但他们无法被强迫以如此热情的方式歌唱。对希特勒政治才能和意志的信任与日俱增。希特勒受到许多人的爱戴。所以希特勒的又一场赌博成功了。
And I think we should take a break at this point. And Dominic, when we come back, there will be more gambles and we will see if they work. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我想我们现在应该休息一下。多米尼克，当我们回来时，会有更多的赌博，我们将看看它们是否奏效。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. And Dominic, the storm clouds of war are gathering. That's what it's all about. How are the Allies responding to the gathering darkness of the storm clouds of war? Well, I'm sure they love the metaphor just as much as we do, Tom. So the Allies at first, the former Allies reaction to hitler's uh reintroduction of conscription and his decision to go for rearmament they are very displeased they meet about a month later in a place called streza in italy uh so this is in april 1935 the british the french and
你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。多米尼克，战争的乌云正在聚集。这就是重点所在。盟国是如何应对战争乌云聚集的黑暗的？嗯，我相信他们和我们一样喜欢这个比喻，汤姆。所以盟国起初，前盟国对希特勒重新引入征兵制和决定进行重整军备的反应，他们非常不满，大约一个月后他们在意大利一个叫斯特雷萨的地方会面，这是在1935年4月，英国人、法国人和
italians and they say right we're going to contain germany we're going to you know make a public statement germany cannot you know the next next place that Germany will probably go for will be Austria. We will guarantee the integrity of Austria. That guarantee will be our kind of public show, our statement that we're not prepared to allow Germany to sort of rip up treaties and behave like a bully boy on the world stage. And the fact that this is happening in Italy, a reminder that Italy had been one of the allies in the First World War, and therefore one of the victors. And Mussolini at this point is still very much on the side
意大利人，他们说，好吧，我们要遏制德国，我们要，你知道，发表公开声明，德国不能，你知道，德国下一个可能的目标将是奥地利。我们将保证奥地利的完整。这一保证将是我们的一种公开展示，是我们声明我们不准备允许德国撕毁条约并在世界舞台上表现得像个恶霸。而且这件事发生在意大利，提醒人们意大利曾是第一次世界大战的盟国之一，因此也是胜利者之一。而墨索里尼此时仍然非常站在
of the two democracies, Britain and France. He is. He is. So Mussolini, whom Hitler thinks Mussolini is brilliant to some degree, and is very influenced by Mussolini, because, of course, Mussolini comes first. But Mussolini had almost, you you know there'd been a danger of war in 1934 over Austria and at this point as you say Mussolini is lined up on the on the other side so the Straser front as it is called it lasts for basically two months and the country that screws it up is not Italy, right? But Britain. But Britain. Yeah. Very disappointing scenes, Tom. So the British and the Germans have been
两个民主国家，英国和法国这一边。确实是。所以墨索里尼，希特勒在某种程度上认为墨索里尼很出色，并且深受墨索里尼的影响，因为当然，墨索里尼是先行者。但墨索里尼几乎，你知道，1934年曾因奥地利问题出现过战争危险，而此时正如你所说，墨索里尼站在了另一边，所以所谓的斯特雷萨阵线基本上只持续了两个月，而搞砸它的国家不是意大利，对吧？而是英国。是英国。是的。非常令人失望的场景，汤姆。所以英国人和德国人一直在
in naval talks. Because as you said before, the British are really most interested in the Royal Navy. And all the time, by the way, the British are looking at the continent and what's going on, but they're distracted by India, by the Great Depression, the empire, all these other things. Worried about Japan as well, aren't they? Yeah, as far as they're concerned. They just want stuff in Central Europe to kind of, they just want Hitler to pipe down, everything to be quiet and stable.
进行海军谈判。因为正如你之前所说，英国人确实最关心皇家海军。顺便说一句，英国人一直都在关注欧洲大陆和正在发生的事情，但他们被印度、大萧条、帝国以及所有其他事情分散了注意力。他们也担心日本，不是吗？是的，就他们而言。他们只是希望中欧的事情能，他们只是希望希特勒安静下来，一切都保持安静和稳定。
They're not that bothered about it. Distant countries of which we know little. Exactly, exactly. So they've been having these naval talks with the Germans, basically allowing the Germans to have a navy that is 35% as big as the British one. And in June 1935, they reach a deal. They reach a deal with a man called Ribbentrop, from whom, unfortunately, the world will be hearing more.
他们对此并不太在意。我们知之甚少的遥远国家。正是，正是。所以他们一直在与德国人进行这些海军谈判，基本上允许德国人拥有一支规模为英国海军35%的海军。1935年6月，他们达成了一项协议。他们与一个叫里宾特洛甫的人达成了协议，不幸的是，世界以后会更多地听到他的名字。
Joachim von Ribbentrop, who is a... He actually fought very bravely in the First World War on an iron cross, but in Britain, he's forever known as a champagne salesman. Yes, a champagne salesman. And a chap who doesn't really, didn't go to the right club. He absolutely didn't go to the right club, Tom. I think because we are a patriotic podcast, we should talk of Ribbentrop and treat him with exactly the same snobbish contempt that people did in Britain.
约阿希姆·冯·里宾特洛甫，他是一个……他在第一次世界大战中确实打得非常勇敢，获得过铁十字勋章，但在英国，他永远被称为香槟推销员。是的，香槟推销员。而且是一个没有真正，没有去过正确俱乐部的人。他绝对没有去过正确的俱乐部，汤姆。我认为因为我们是一个爱国播客，我们应该谈论里宾特洛甫，并以英国人对待他时那种势利的蔑视来对待他。
Whatever I would have done. He's definitely a guy who wears the wrong shoes. He absolutely is. He's always got the wrong trousers on. Well, they're shiny. He's trying too hard. Yeah. You know, he's always trying too hard and wearing a very sharp, expensive suit that's just ill-judged.
无论我做了什么。他绝对是一个穿错鞋的人。他绝对是。他总是穿错裤子。嗯，它们很亮。他太刻意了。是的。你知道，他总是太刻意，穿着一套非常时髦、昂贵但却不得体的西装。
Not wearing baggy tweed. Yeah, exactly. He's a terrible man and everyone in Britain despises him. And he knows this and he absolutely loathes the British. But it's Ribbentrop who concludes this naval deal with the British in 1935. And this again, you know, the British have basically gone behind the backs of the French to do this deal with the Germans because the British think, ah, give them a few of these things, which are not unreasonable, it's not unreasonable for the Germans to ask for a navy. You can't hold them responsible for 1914 forever. At some point, you're going to have to let them have a navy. Let it be now. Let's buy them off. And of course, to Hitler, that sends the message, you can always divide and rule. You can always persuade either the British or the French to go behind the backs of the other one and to give you what you want. So the Straser front is pretty much dead from that point onwards, because it's obvious the
没穿宽松的粗花呢。是的，正是。他是个糟糕的人，英国所有人都鄙视他。他知道这一点，而且他绝对痛恨英国人。但正是里宾特洛甫在1935年与英国人达成了这项海军协议。这再次，你知道，英国人基本上背着法国人与德国人达成了这项协议，因为英国人认为，啊，给他们一些这些东西，这并不过分，德国人要求拥有一支海军并不过分。你不能永远让他们为1914年负责。在某个时候，你必须让他们拥有一支海军。就现在吧。让我们收买他们。当然，对希特勒来说，这传达了一个信息，你可以随时分而治之。你总是可以说服英国人或法国人背着对方，给你想要的东西。所以斯特雷萨阵线从那时起基本上就名存实亡了，因为很明显
Allies are never really going to act in concert. And at this point, so the middle to end of 1935, it has to be said, Hitler has played his hand unbelievably well. I mean, Ian Kershaw, in his brilliant biography of Hitler, he writes as follows. He says, for the German people, Hitler seemed to be achieving the unimaginable. He had, it seemed, single-handedly broken the shackles of Versailles, restored military pride, and made Germany once more a force to be reckoned with in international affairs. And Kershaw also says, I think really importantly, at this point, and I quote, there was nothing specifically Nazi about his achievements. Any patriotic German could find something to admire in them.
盟国永远不会真正齐心协力。而在这一点上，也就是1935年中后期，必须说，希特勒的牌打得好得令人难以置信。我的意思是，伊恩·克肖在他那本精彩的希特勒传记中这样写道。他说，对于德国人民来说，希特勒似乎正在实现不可思议的事情。他似乎单枪匹马地打破了凡尔赛的枷锁，恢复了军事自豪感，并使德国再次成为国际事务中不可忽视的力量。克肖还说，我认为这一点非常重要，我引用一下，他的成就中没有任何特别纳粹的东西。任何爱国的德国人都能在其中找到值得钦佩的地方。
And I think that's really important that people get that. At this point, you might disapprove of Hitler domestically. But if you have even an ounce of kind of patriotic pride in Germany, you would say, we should have a navy. navy you know we should have the czar land you know all of these kinds of we should be proud and have our territorial integrity and all these kinds of things obviously the the drive to rearmament requires an emphasis on guns rather than on butter and i was again really interested reading adam twos and he, remarkable evidence collected by labor historians demonstrates the passionate identification that many German workers in the 1930s clearly felt with the weapons they were producing. And he says that in part, this is because of the high status that's attached to the skilled to do with with the armaments themselves that they are assertions of national strength yeah that the average worker is made to feel good about what
我认为人们理解这一点非常重要。在这一点上，你可能在国内政策上不赞同希特勒。但如果你对德国有一丁点爱国自豪感，你会说，我们应该拥有一支海军。你知道，我们应该拥有萨尔地区，你知道所有这些，我们应该感到自豪并拥有我们的领土完整，所有这些事情。显然，重整军备的动力需要强调大炮而不是黄油，我再次对阅读亚当·图兹的书非常感兴趣，他收集的劳工历史学家的非凡证据证明了许多德国工人在20世纪30年代对自己生产的武器所感受到的强烈认同感。他说，在某种程度上，这是因为熟练工人所拥有的高地位，与武器本身有关，它们是国家力量的宣示，是的，普通工人对自己所生产的东西感到自豪
he's producing and that presumably this is something that steals workers in the face of the sacrifice that the process of realment requires of them because if money is being invested in armaments it's not being invested in consumer durables. Yeah, you're absolutely right. I think that Adam Too's point is really important. There's nothing wrong with being patriotic, and there's nothing wrong with being a patriotic German. And we joke, Tom, about being a patriotic podcast, for example. Had you been in Germany in the 1930s, early early 1930s you might well have been horrified by all kinds of hitler's domestic policies regarded hitler himself as a very bad man been shocked by the anti-semitism the violence the dictatorship all those things but if you in 1935 had looked at
而这大概就是让工人在重整军备过程所要求的牺牲面前变得坚强的原因，因为如果资金被投入到军备中，它就不会被投入到耐用消费品中。是的，你说得完全正确。我认为亚当·图兹的观点非常重要。爱国没有错，做一个爱国的德国人也没有错。汤姆，我们开玩笑说我们是一个爱国播客，例如。如果你在20世纪30年代的德国，20世纪30年代初，你很可能会对希特勒的各种国内政策感到震惊，认为希特勒本人是一个非常坏的人，对反犹太主义、暴力、独裁所有这些事情感到震惊，但如果你在1935年审视
all his foreign policy achievements and had looked at the guns being produced and the emphasis on an army and all that stuff the chances are that you would say, you know, great, good. I mean, the other stuff I don't like, but this I do approve of. Because as Kershaw says, any nationalistic German would have felt like that. And I think a lot of workers, absolutely, they have things they resent. But as you say, the problem is you can't have everything. Right. And because they are spending their, they have very little hard currency.
他所有的外交政策成就，审视正在生产的大炮以及对军队的重视等等，你很可能会说，你知道，太棒了，很好。我的意思是，其他我不喜欢的东西，但这我赞同。因为正如克肖所说，任何民族主义的德国人都会有这种感觉。我认为很多工人，绝对，他们有他们怨恨的事情。但正如你所说，问题是你不能拥有一切。对。而且因为他们正在花费他们的，他们几乎没有硬通货。
They don't have much foreign exchange, but they are spending so much of it on expanding armaments that there's not much left over for the rest of the economy. And so in late 1935, the consequences of Hitler's choices become very apparent to most Germans because they're basically, they start running out of food. Right. And so at this point, the kind of patriotic feeling that, oh, brilliant, we're rearming starts to run up against the fact that the shops are empty. Exactly. So this is something that actually, if you're just, you know, image of the Third Reich, if it's all kind of Lenin-Riefenstahl, autobahns, you know. Afraid to say it probably is in my case, but. Shining factories and stuff. It's easy to miss this, that actually for ordinary Germans, life is sometimes very, very hard. And as we said, also, that the German economy is actually...
他们没有多少外汇，但他们把其中的大部分都花在了扩大军备上，以至于经济的其他部分所剩无几。因此，在1935年底，希特勒选择的后果对大多数德国人来说变得非常明显，因为他们基本上，他们开始缺粮了。对。所以在这个时候，那种“太棒了，我们在重整军备”的爱国情绪开始与商店空空如也的事实发生碰撞。正是。所以这实际上是，如果你只是，你知道，第三帝国的形象，如果全是莱尼·里芬斯塔尔、高速公路，你知道。恐怕在我的情况下确实如此，但是。闪亮的工厂之类的。很容易忽略这一点，实际上对于普通德国人来说，生活有时非常非常艰难。正如我们所说，德国经济实际上也……
I hadn't realized until I read the Adam Tooze just how backward it was. Yeah, and it's also on very sort of weak foundations. So the one thing they were always running out of is fats. They have a massive problem with fats, don't they? So they're always running out of sort of butter and vegetable oil and things like this and there are massive queues in the shops that actually sales of butter at the end of 1935 have to be overseen by the police because people are fighting over butter meat is incredibly expensive the cost of frozen meat for example is going has gone up by 70 percent and as you say, in different circumstances, this would lead to
在读亚当·图兹之前，我没有意识到它有多落后。是的，而且它建立在非常脆弱的基础上。所以他们总是短缺的一件事是脂肪。他们在脂肪方面有一个巨大的问题，不是吗？所以他们总是短缺黄油和植物油之类的东西，商店里排着长队，实际上1935年底黄油的销售必须由警察监督，因为人们在为黄油打架，肉类极其昂贵，例如冷冻肉的价格上涨了70%，正如你所说，在不同的情况下，这会导致
riots. People would be furious. And people are very discontented sometimes about the authorities. But Hitler has a knack of pulling out of the bag these foreign policy coups that buy him another six months. I mean, Hitler himself, he's seen as very abstemious, isn't he? Yes. A devoted servant to the German people because he doesn't draw his salary as reich's chancellor because basically he can live off the the royalties of mein kampf apart from anything else yeah but there are there are figures who are more extravagant yeah and i guess goering would be the archetype of that because he's building himself hunting lodges isn't he and he's got kind of jeweled scepters and there's a kind of brilliant description of him by
骚乱。人们会非常愤怒。人们有时对当局非常不满。但希特勒有一种从包里掏出外交政策政变的能力，这为他赢得了又一个六个月的时间。我的意思是，希特勒本人，他被视为非常节制，不是吗？是的。一个忠诚的德国人民公仆，因为他不领取帝国总理的薪水，因为基本上他可以靠《我的奋斗》的版税生活，除此以外。是的，但有一些人更奢侈。是的，我想戈林会是其中的典型，因为他正在为自己建造狩猎小屋，不是吗？他有珠宝权杖，而且有一个关于他的精彩描述，来自
by ciano who's he's muslim his son-in-law isn't he um who runs into goring wearing a fur coat that resembled what a high-grade prostitute wears to the opera so all of this kind of goring fur coat malarkey i mean this must be going down quite badly if there's nothing in the shops agreed going is such a peculiar figure because he'd been a great war hero and he'd been, after the First World War, he was seen as something of a matinee idol, you know, a very dashing... He was in the Red Baron Squadron, wasn't he? Yeah. And what actually happens to him is it's as though he's attached to an air pump and every year somebody pumps him up a bit more. So he's getting fatter and fatter.
齐亚诺，他是墨索里尼的女婿，不是吗？他遇到了穿着一件皮大衣的戈林，那件大衣看起来像高级妓女去歌剧院穿的那样。所以所有这些关于戈林皮大衣的胡闹，我的意思是，如果商店里什么都没有，这肯定会产生非常糟糕的影响。同意，戈林是一个如此奇特的人物，因为他曾是一位伟大的战争英雄，在第一次世界大战后，他被视为某种偶像，你知道，非常潇洒……他在红男爵中队，不是吗？是的。而他身上实际发生的事情是，就好像他连接到了一个气泵上，每年有人把他充气更多一点。所以他变得越来越胖。
More and more ludicrous costumes. Yeah. And his costumes, he loves a kind of white tunic or white boots and all this kind of stuff. And hunting, as you say, massive meals and paintings. So there are a lot of people who say, oh, I hate the Nazi bigwigs. You know, they're bullies. They strut around. They live high on the…
越来越荒谬的服装。是的。他的服装，他喜欢那种白色束腰外衣或白色靴子之类的东西。还有狩猎，正如你所说，大量的食物和绘画。所以有很多人说，哦，我讨厌纳粹大人物。你知道，他们是恶霸。他们昂首阔步。他们生活在……
High on the hog. High on the hog, exactly. That's the expression I was groping for. Yeah. They're stuffing themselves with quails. Well, we can't get it. The fats we need. But no one says this about Hitler.
生活在奢华中。生活在奢华中，正是。那是我一直在寻找的表达方式。是的。他们用鹌鹑填满自己。嗯，我们买不到。我们需要脂肪。但没有人这样说希特勒。
It's like a medieval king. They say he's poorly advised. But the king himself, if he knew of our plight, would be... But he's seen also as monkish, isn't he? Yes, exactly. Kind of austere. I mean, the fact that he's kind of sitting around watching Mickey Mouse. And not getting up till lunchtime.
就像中世纪的国王。他们说他被误导了。但国王本人，如果他知道我们的困境，会……但他也被视为像僧侣一样，不是吗？是的，正是。那种朴素。我的意思是，他坐在那里看米老鼠的事实。而且不到午餐时间不起床。
Yeah, but this isn't factoring through at all. No, no, not at all. They think he's incredibly hardworking, which of course he isn't. Anyway, as you rightly say, at the end of 1935, the fact that his economics is so terrible. I mean, it's bonkers, his economic agenda, which is to try and have everything and not to face any of the hard choices. That this has got Germany into real trouble.
是的，但这根本没有被考虑进去。不，不，根本没有。他们认为他非常勤奋，当然他不是。无论如何，正如你正确所说，在1935年底，他的经济学是如此糟糕的事实。我的意思是，他的经济议程是疯狂的，那就是试图拥有一切而不面对任何艰难的选择。这让德国陷入了真正的麻烦。
And he needs another foreign policy coup. It's at this point that he decides, I'm going to go for the big one. And the big one is the Rhineland. So you said in the first half about how important this was, that this huge slice of Western Germany has been forcibly kind of demilitarized. The Germans are not allowed to station troops on the banks of the Rhine. And what that means is that the French can walk in
他需要另一次外交政策政变。就在这时，他决定，我要去争取那个大的。而那个大的就是莱茵兰。所以你在上半部分说了这有多重要，这块巨大的德国西部地区被强行非军事化了。德国人不允许在莱茵河畔驻军。这意味着法国人可以随意走进来
at will and just, you know, whatever the Germans do, the Germans will always be on the defensive. They can never attack the French. The French would always be attacking them. They have a spear pointed at the soft underbelly of the German economy. Very good. One might almost say. Yes. And Dominic, would you say it's fair to say that for the average German, the French are seen as the enemy?
并且只是，你知道，无论德国人做什么，德国人总是处于防御状态。他们永远无法攻击法国人。法国人总是会攻击他们。他们有一把矛指向德国经济的软肋。非常好。人们几乎可以说。是的。多米尼克，你会说对于普通德国人来说，法国人被视为敌人是公平的吗？
They are, absolutely. At this point, by the way hitler is still quite keen on an alliance with britain he has very mixed feelings about the british a bit like the kaiser he kind of um envies the british he sees them as a great imperial power well they're anglo-saxon aren't they anglo-saxons exactly so they're kind of racial brethren but at the same time he's resent you know the british are always mocking his emissaries shoes or whatever it might be exactly and behaving snobbish i mean it's just it's just you know the cow's week with the kaiser it just continues right all over again never ends that's never a tragedy yeah anyway the rhineland so the issue that rhineland is not strategic for germany i mean it's such a humiliation this really rich and important
他们是，绝对。顺便说一句，此时希特勒仍然非常热衷于与英国结盟，他对英国人有非常复杂的感觉，有点像德皇，他有点羡慕英国人，他视他们为一个伟大的帝国强权，嗯，他们是盎格鲁-撒克逊人，不是吗？盎格鲁-撒克逊人，正是。所以他们是某种种族兄弟，但与此同时，他怨恨，你知道，英国人总是嘲笑他的特使的鞋子或类似的东西，正是，表现得势利。我的意思是，这只是，你知道，德皇的考斯周，它只是继续，一遍又一遍，永无止境，那从来都不是悲剧。是的，无论如何，莱茵兰。所以莱茵兰的问题对德国来说不是战略性的，我的意思是，这是一种耻辱，这块你国家中如此富有和重要的
part of your country, and you're not allowed to put your own troops in it. The analogy would be if Britain were banned from stationing troops in the home counties. I mean, whether or not you wanted to, it would just be such a massive affront to your national pride. And Hitler realizes in the early months of 1936 that actually the chance to do this is becoming greater and greater not least because that sort of tacit that implicit alliance between Britain, France and Italy
部分，而你不被允许在其中驻扎自己的军队。类比就是如果英国被禁止在本土郡驻军。我的意思是，无论你是否想，这都将是对你民族自尊心的巨大侮辱。希特勒在1936年初意识到，实际上做这件事的机会越来越大，不仅因为那种英国、法国和意大利之间默示的、隐含的联盟
has pretty much broken up the Italians have disgraced themselves by invading Abyssinia the previous year. A new Roman Empire. To try and build a new Roman Empire. So they've kind of been kicked out of the club of democracies. So the opportunity for a kind of rapprochement where Mussolini is there,
已经基本破裂了。意大利人因前一年入侵阿比西尼亚而丢尽了脸。一个新的罗马帝国。试图建立一个新的罗马帝国。所以他们被踢出了民主国家俱乐部。所以那种墨索里尼在场时的和解机会，
it's pretty much on the table at this point. He knows, his intelligence is telling him, his ambassadors, diplomats, and so on, is saying, the French are actually not going to do anything about it. If you do it, the French will be very, very annoyed. But they are too weak. They're too divided in France. France is very domestically divided at this point. But are they too weak? I mean, in military terms, they're presumably not. No, not in military terms. Tom, I'm tapping my head, my temple, like a football manager telling his team to regroup after
在这一点上基本上是摆在桌面上的。他知道，他的情报告诉他，他的大使、外交官等等，都在说，法国人实际上不会对此做任何事情。如果你做了，法国人会非常非常恼火。但他们太弱了。他们在法国太分裂了。法国此时在国内非常分裂。但他们太弱了吗？我的意思是，在军事上，他们大概不是。不，不是在军事上。汤姆，我正在敲我的头，我的太阳穴，就像一个足球教练在球队丢了一个灾难性的球后告诉他的球队重新集结一样
conceding a disastrous goal. They're choking. They are mentally shot. Yeah, they're chokers. Yeah. They are riddled with self-doubt and domestic division. The British, I mean, have made it pretty clear they don't give a damn what goes on in Central Europe.
他们窒息了。他们在精神上崩溃了。是的，他们是软脚虾。是的。他们充满了自我怀疑和国内分裂。英国人，我的意思是，已经说得很清楚，他们不在乎中欧发生了什么。
I mean, Stanley Baldwin is prime minister, and much as I love Stanley Baldwin, he's never going to do anything about anything. So, you know, they're just going to let the Germans crack on and do what they want. Continuing the football analogy, this is like England refusing to play in the World Cup. Yeah. You know, it's not their business. They've got bigger fish to fry. Yeah, we've got bigger fish to fry.
我的意思是，斯坦利·鲍德温是首相，尽管我喜欢斯坦利·鲍德温，但他永远不会对任何事情采取行动。所以，你知道，他们只是会让德国人继续做他们想做的事。继续足球类比，这就像英格兰拒绝参加世界杯。是的。你知道，这不关他们的事。他们有更重要的事情要做。是的，我们有更重要的事情要做。
Yeah. But also the British think, you know, why shouldn't the Germans have troops in the Rhineland? George Bernard Shaw said, you know, but it's like us sending troops to Portsmouth. Why wouldn't you have troops in Portsmouth? If you're an anti-appeasement historian, let's say, you say, oh my gosh, what a chance missed. This was the opportunity. Germany would never be so weak again. This was the moment. But it was. I mean, to be fair, wasn't it? It was the opportunity. But to me, it's inconceivable that the British and the French would have, I mean, to be fair, wasn't it? It was the opportunity. But to me, it's inconceivable that the British and the French would have, I mean, certainly inconceivable the British would have.
是的。但英国人也认为，你知道，为什么德国人不能在莱茵兰驻军？萧伯纳说，你知道，但这就像我们向朴茨茅斯派遣军队。为什么你不能在朴茨茅斯驻军？如果你是一个反绥靖政策的历史学家，比如说，你会说，天哪，错过了什么机会。这就是机会。德国再也不会这么弱了。这就是时刻。但确实是。我的意思是，公平地说，不是吗？这就是机会。但对我来说，英国和法国会……我的意思是，当然不可思议的是英国会。
Imagine in the mid 1930s. But if the French had moved in, I mean, it would have worked militarily. They would, because basically, doesn't Hitler kind of deceive the French? He recruits loads of people from the police to dress up in the army to make it look as if it's a much bigger force than it actually is when they move in. So just to give you an indication of how he comes to the decision, by the way, because it involves another hotel. He's at another hotel in Munich. This time Goebbels is actually staying at the hotel and Hitler arrives in the lobby and says,
想象一下20世纪30年代中期。但如果法国人进去了，我的意思是，它在军事上会奏效。他们会，因为基本上，希特勒不是欺骗了法国人吗？他招募了大量警察伪装成军队，使它看起来比实际进入时要强大得多。所以只是为了让你了解他是如何做出决定的，顺便说一句，因为它涉及另一家酒店。他在慕尼黑的另一家酒店。这次戈培尔实际上住在酒店里，希特勒到达大厅并说，
I've come to see Goebbels. And he says to Goebbels, I've decided to go for it. I want to remilitarize the Rhineland. I'm going to send in the troops. Goebbels writes in his diary. Goebbels loves a cliche as well, Tom. Does he? Fortune favors the brave. Well, he who dares nothing wins nothing, says Goebbels. That's very true. And had Goebbels been enjoying the buffet? Do we know? Breakfast buffet. No, I don't see them as having a buffet in that kind
我来看戈培尔。他对戈培尔说，我决定去做了。我想让莱茵兰重新军事化。我要派军队进去。戈培尔在他的日记中写道。戈培尔也喜欢陈词滥调，汤姆。是吗？幸运眷顾勇敢者。嗯，不入虎穴，焉得虎子，戈培尔说。那是非常真实的。如果戈培尔一直在享用自助餐？我们知道吗？早餐自助餐。不，我不认为他们在那种酒店有自助餐
of hotel. I think that's a la carte. carte. So as you say, they are going to send in 30,000 troops. I mean, a lot of these people are policemen disguised as troops. And actually of those, only a tiny fraction will go forward really deep into the Rhineland. The rest will hang around at the back. So just to repeat, if the French had sent an army in, I mean, I entirely take your point that they were never going to because they were mentally shot. But if they had, it would have... Totally worked. The Germans wouldn't have been able to occupy the Rhineland. The humiliation to Hitler would have been very profound. And a line would have been drawn in the sand that perhaps might have brought Hitler down. I mean, it's not wrong to argue that, is it?
我认为那是点菜的。所以正如你所说，他们要派进3万名士兵。我的意思是，这些人中很多是伪装成士兵的警察。实际上，其中只有一小部分会真正深入莱茵兰。其余的会徘徊在后面。所以只是重复一遍，如果法国人派了一支军队进去，我的意思是，我完全接受你的观点，他们永远不会，因为他们在精神上崩溃了。但如果他们做了，它会……完全奏效。德国人将无法占领莱茵兰。对希特勒的羞辱将是非常深刻的。而且会在沙滩上画一条线，这也许会把希特勒拉下马。我的意思是，争论这一点并没有错，不是吗？
It's not wrong. Do you know what, Tom? It would have taken the French only one division. If they had sent even one division across, Hitler's instructions to his troops were basically fall back immediately. We can't win, no confrontation. He's very nervous when it comes to it. And we will get to the extraordinary set piece of his announcement in a second, but you are dead right. It would have worked. The French were never, ever going to do it. Hitler had read the runes correctly the French were much too divided but also I think there are a couple of things to bear in mind number one is there is a widespread sense in western Europe we have been much too hard on the Germans and that is what has led to this situation that is why Hitler is there because so many Germans feel humiliated, resentful, victimized. If we keep doing this, if we keep attacking the Germans and keep punishing them, this
并没有错。你知道吗，汤姆？法国人只需要一个师。如果他们哪怕派了一个师过去，希特勒给他的军队的指示基本上是立即撤退。我们赢不了，不要对抗。当事情发生时，他非常紧张。我们稍后会谈到他宣布的非凡场景，但你是完全正确的。它会奏效。法国人永远永远不会这样做。希特勒正确地解读了符文，法国人太分裂了，但我也认为有几件事要记住，第一点是西欧有一种普遍的感觉，我们对德国人太严厉了，这就是导致这种情况的原因，这就是为什么希特勒在那里，因为许多德国人感到羞辱、怨恨、受害。如果我们继续这样做，如果我们继续攻击德国人并继续惩罚他们，这个
pattern will just repeat that they will elect or they will turn to demagogic strongmen and we'll just be stuck in this cycle forever. So that's point one. Yeah. They might turn to someone even worse than Hitler. I mean, is that seriously what they're thinking? How could anyone be worse than Hitler? Well, because don't forget, at this point, Hitler hasn't started a war.
模式只会重复，他们会选举或转向煽动性的强人，我们将永远陷入这个循环。所以这是第一点。是的。他们可能会转向比希特勒更糟糕的人。我的意思是，他们真的是这么想的吗？怎么会有人比希特勒更糟糕？嗯，因为别忘了，在这一点上，希特勒还没有发动战争。
Hitler hasn't invaded anybody. Yeah. So at this point... But they've read Mein Kampf, presumably, in the higher echelons of government. But a lot of them haven't, or they think it's just adolescent ranting. They don't know what we know, Tom. Second point, they are absolutely transfixed by the necessity of not having another great war. You can't understand any of the decisions people are taking without bearing in mind the horrendous experience. I entirely understand that.
希特勒还没有入侵任何人。是的。所以在这个时候……但他们读过《我的奋斗》，大概在政府的高层。但他们很多人没有读过，或者他们认为这只是青少年的咆哮。他们不知道我们所知道的，汤姆。第二点，他们完全被必须不发生另一场大战的必要性所吸引。如果不记住那段可怕的经历，你就无法理解人们正在做出的任何决定。我完全理解这一点。
And by the way, they think a second war will be far, far worse because of air power and bombing. Of course, because the bomber always gets through and everything. Of course, I get that. But having said that, their intelligence is faulty. They think that the forces occupying the Rhineland are much greater than they actually are. And that is a failure of intelligence. And if they'd had the intelligence, they would have realised that it wouldn't have precipitated a world war. And it would have been like the occupation of the Ruhr in the 20s. Tom, I don't disagree with that at all. I mean, I think you're absolutely right.
顺便说一句，他们认为第二次战争会因为空中力量和轰炸而变得远比第一次糟糕。当然，因为轰炸机总是能穿透一切。当然，我明白这一点。但话虽如此，他们的情报是有缺陷的。他们认为占领莱茵兰的部队比实际要强大得多。这是情报的失败。如果他们有情报，他们就会意识到这不会引发世界大战。这就像20年代对鲁尔区的占领。汤姆，我一点也不反对这一点。我的意思是，我认为你是完全正确的。
They could have done it. They absolutely could have done it. I mean, the French, if they wanted, could have been in Berlin for tea, but they weren't going to do it. Yeah. All right. And so this is Hitler's malign ability to sniff out weakness and to act on it. And he also, of course, as you described so brilliantly last week, he's a brilliant performer, and he and his team are brilliant at staging these set pieces.
他们本可以做到的。他们绝对本可以做到的。我的意思是，法国人，如果他们愿意，本可以在柏林喝茶，但他们不会这样做。是的。好吧。所以这就是希特勒嗅出弱点并据此行动的恶毒能力。而且他当然，正如你上周描述得如此精彩的那样，他是一位出色的表演者，他和他的团队非常擅长策划这些场景。
And then this is one of his most remarkable appearances. The Reichstag on Saturday, the 7th of March, 1936, a meeting in a building called the Kroll Opera House, because, of course, the Reichstag has been burned down, and it hasn't yet been rebuilt. All the Nazi top brass are there. They're all very nervous. Wernher von Blumberg,
然后这是他最引人注目的露面之一。1936年3月7日星期六的国会大厦，在克罗尔歌剧院的一场会议，因为，当然，国会大厦已经被烧毁了，而且还没有重建。所有纳粹高层都在那里。他们都非常紧张。维尔纳·冯·布隆伯格，
the head of the army, is kind of supposedly pale with tension because they know the French could do exactly as you say. The speech is going to be broadcast on the radio. So millions of people are listening.
军队首脑，因为他们知道法国人可以完全按照你说的做，所以他紧张得脸色苍白。演讲将在广播中播出。所以数百万人正在收听。
And Hitler starts talking about Germany's humiliation. He says the French are very bad people. And he says, the French, by the way, have just signed an agreement with the Soviet Union,
希特勒开始谈论德国的羞辱。他说法国人是非常坏的人。他说，顺便说一句，法国人刚刚与苏联签署了一项协议，
you know, encircling us. So we have to do something about it. So we're the real victims here. We are the real victims. And he says, because of all this, the pacts of the 1920s have kind of lost their value. We don't regard ourselves as bound by them. And then he says, the German Reich government has therefore from today restored the full and unrestricted sovereignty of the Reich in the demilitarized zone of the Rhineland. And you quoted a guy in your last episode called William L. Shira, American correspondent. And he has this amazing description of the deputies jumping to their feet and they are screaming. Is this the little men with big bodies and bulging necks and cropped hair and pouched bellies and brown uniforms and heavy boots little men of clay in his fine hands yeah amazing and they're screaming
你知道，包围我们。所以我们必须对此做点什么。所以我们才是真正的受害者。我们才是真正的受害者。他说，因为这一切，20年代的条约已经失去了它们的价值。我们不认为自己受它们约束。然后他说，因此，德国帝国政府从今天起恢复了帝国在莱茵兰非军事区的全部和不受限制的主权。你在上一集中引用了一个叫威廉·L·夏伊勒的人，美国记者。他有这个惊人的描述，代表们跳了起来，他们尖叫着。这是那些有着大身体、鼓起的脖子、剪短的头发、鼓起的肚子、棕色制服和沉重靴子的小个子男人，他那双精细的手中的泥塑小人，是的，太棒了，他们尖叫着
with delight and hitler raises a hand for silence then he says men of the german reichstag and you can hear a pin drop and he says in this historic hour when in the reichs western provinces german troops are at this minute marching into their future peacetime garrisons we all unite in two sacred vows and then he can't go on because the hubbub the sobbing the cheering the applause the salutes the hiles is so great and as um sarah says they were shouting shouting their eyes burning with fanaticism glued on their new God, the Messiah. I mean, that is how loads of Germans think. Because at that moment, one o'clock, as Hitler was speaking, his troops are crossing the Hohenzollern Bridge in Cologne. There are
带着喜悦，希特勒举起一只手要求安静，然后他说，德国国会的男人们，你可以听到针掉在地上的声音，他说，在这个历史性的时刻，当在帝国的西部省份，德国军队此刻正在向他们未来的和平时期驻军进军时，我们所有人团结在两个神圣的誓言中，然后他无法继续，因为喧闹声、啜泣声、欢呼声、掌声、敬礼、希特勒万岁声太大了，正如萨拉所说，他们在大喊大叫，他们的眼睛燃烧着狂热，紧盯着他们的新神，弥赛亚。我的意思是，这就是许多德国人的想法。因为在那一刻，一点钟，当希特勒讲话时，他的军队正在穿过科隆的霍亨索伦大桥。有
thousands of people in the streets. Word has got around. People are throwing flowers. Women are crying. There are Catholic priests blessing them. And the French do nothing. And the joy of the German people is unconfined. And this presumably completely alters the strategic balance because now the French no longer have that bayonet point sticking into the soft underbelly of the German economy. Now the French have no option really but to kind of institute a defensive policy. Exactly.
街上有成千上万的人。消息已经传开了。人们在扔花。女人们在哭泣。有天主教神父在祝福他们。而法国人什么也没做。德国人民的喜悦是无边无际的。这大概完全改变了战略平衡，因为现在法国人不再有那把刺入德国经济软肋的刺刀了。现在法国人真的别无选择，只能采取防御政策。正是。
The offensive opportunity has gone. Exactly. This totally changes the strategic map of Europe. Now, when the French are looking at a war, they're thinking about being on the defensive. They will no longer just be able to march across the Rhine. It will actually be the Germans who are now able to strike into France. So that changes things. It also changes things, I think.
进攻的机会已经消失了。正是。这完全改变了欧洲的战略地图。现在，当法国人审视战争时，他们考虑的是处于防御状态。他们将不再能够直接穿过莱茵河。实际上将是德国人现在能够打击法国。所以这改变了事情。我也认为它改变了事情。
It obviously buoys up Hitler's popularity. All the crisis about the fats, I mean, that hasn't gone away, but nobody's thinking about butter now. They're so excited about the Rhineland. So that person we quoted earlier, the housewife, Louisa Solomitz, I was totally overwhelmed by the events of this hour, overjoyed at the entry march of our soldiers at the greatness of hitler and the power of his speech the force of this man now this is somebody whose whose domestic life has been you know upended by race laws by nazi race laws but she still thinks god this is amazing what a man Hitler is. And the thing is, it's clear that from this point, Hitler himself believes it.
它显然提振了希特勒的声望。所有关于脂肪的危机，我的意思是，那并没有消失，但现在没有人想到黄油了。他们对莱茵兰感到如此兴奋。所以我们之前引用的那个人，家庭主妇路易莎·索洛米茨，我被这一刻的事件完全淹没了，为我们士兵的进入行军，为希特勒的伟大和他演讲的力量而欣喜若狂，这个人的力量，现在这是一个家庭生活被种族法，纳粹种族法颠覆的人，但她仍然认为，上帝，这太棒了，希特勒是一个什么样的人。问题是，很明显，从这一点开始，希特勒本人相信了这一点。
He had once, Tom, when we did the first series about the rise of the Nazis, we talked about how at the beginning, Hitler had seen himself as the drummer, the guy who would... The John the Baptist. Yeah. At this point, 1936, this convinces him, I think. This really convinces him. He is the Messiah. That he is the Messiah. It. At this point, 1936, this convinces him, I think. This really convinces him. He is the Messiah.
汤姆，当我们做关于纳粹崛起的第一系列节目时，我们谈到希特勒在开始时如何将自己视为鼓手，那个会……施洗约翰。是的。在这一点上，1936年，这说服了他，我想。这真的说服了他。他是弥赛亚。他是弥赛亚。在这一点上，1936年，这说服了他，我想。这真的说服了他。他是弥赛亚。
That he is the Messiah. It's not just a metaphor. He thinks, he genuinely thinks, providence. He starts to use the word providence or destiny a lot. He thinks that providence has chosen, because all of these gambles have worked. Now, I suppose the question would be, what if he had stopped there? And if he had stopped there, which he could have done, he would have gone down as an exceedingly successful nationalistic leader of Germany.
他是弥赛亚。这不仅仅是一个比喻。他认为，他真诚地认为，天意。他开始大量使用天意或命运这个词。他认为天意选择了，因为所有这些赌博都成功了。现在，我想问题是，如果他在那里停下来会怎样？如果他在那里停下来，他本可以做到，他将作为德国一位极其成功的民族主义领导人被载入史册。
But of course, the nature of what you were talking about, the Adam Tooze stuff, the economy, the will to power as well, and all of that, and the very nature of his ideology, which goes back to what we said right at the very beginning, he cannot stop there. There will always be something more. And actually, at the end of 1936, they take a decision that they will go all in on this economic program of autarky, which is self-sufficiency, of rearming. Goering is in charge of something called the Four Year Plan. Hitler sends a memo, which Goering reads to his cabinet. And Hitler says,
但当然，你所谈论的本质，亚当·图兹的东西，经济，权力意志，以及所有这些，以及他意识形态的本质，这回到了我们在最开始所说的，他不能在那里停下来。总会有更多的事情。实际上，在1936年底，他们做出了一个决定，他们将全力投入到这个自给自足的经济计划中，也就是自给自足，重整军备。戈林负责一个叫四年计划的东西。希特勒发了一份备忘录，戈林向他的内阁宣读了这份备忘录。希特勒说，
we are approaching a confrontation with worldwide Jewry, Jewishness, for which Bolshevism is really just the front. The Jews are behind Bolshevism. And he says, this is going to be an all-out existential struggle. We must be fit for war in four years go absolutely all in we now have a new pal in europe italy he's also of course we don't really have time to go into it and massively but both germany and italy are now intervening in the spanish civil war on the side of franco so that's brought them closer together so this is when guernica happens and they're trying out bombing techniques with the lwaffe. Exactly. In November 1936, so about just after Hitler has said, I plan to rearm completely and be ready for war in four years,
我们正在接近与全世界犹太人的对抗，犹太性，布尔什维克主义实际上只是它的幌子。犹太人在布尔什维克主义背后。他说，这将是一场全面的生存斗争。我们必须在四年内为战争做好准备，全力以赴。我们现在在欧洲有了一个新伙伴意大利，他当然，我们没有太多时间深入讨论，但德国和意大利现在都在西班牙内战中站在佛朗哥一边进行干预，所以这使他们走得更近了，所以这就是格尔尼卡发生的时候，他们正在用德国空军尝试轰炸技术。正是。1936年11月，也就是希特勒说，我计划全面重整军备并在四年内为战争做好准备之后，
Mussolini starts to use the phrase, the axis. He says it in Milan in a speech in front of the cathedral. He says, Rome and Berlin is the axis around which Europe now revolves. At the end of that month, November 1936, Hitler approves the anti-comintern pact with Japan. So he now has an Asian ally as well. Which is very menacing for Britain. Yeah.
墨索里尼开始使用“轴心”这个词。他在米兰大教堂前的一次演讲中说了出来。他说，罗马和柏林是欧洲现在围绕其旋转的轴心。那个月底，1936年11月，希特勒批准了与日本的《反共产国际协定》。所以他现在也有了一个亚洲盟友。这对英国来说是非常危险的。是的。
Irredentist power, which is keen to carve out an empire, to undo the work of the treaties in the 1920s. And there's a real sense, I think, at this point, 1936, 1937, that Hitler is seized with a sense of mission. For the first time, he thinks, I am actually going to do all this. I'm not just laying the foundations for somebody else in foreign policy, for a future regime, for my successor. I can achieve the greater Germany in my lifetime. And he's a terrible hypochondriac,'t he hitler so he's
领土收复主义强权，热衷于开辟帝国，撤销20年代条约的工作。我认为在1936年、1937年，有一种真正的感觉，希特勒被一种使命感所占据。这是第一次，他认为，我实际上要完成所有这些。我不仅仅是在为外交政策中的其他人，为未来的政权，为我的继任者奠定基础。我可以在我有生之年实现大德意志。而且他是一个可怕的疑病症患者，不是吗，希特勒，所以他……
always having kind of stomach spasms and eczema and stuff and thinking that this is about cancer isn't he because his his mother died of cancer and exactly he's also doing this absolutely bizarre thing tom i mean the thing with hitler is that you say about your wes anderson film i mean obviously it's an unbelievably dark and terrible story, but there are these weird comic elements. So Hitler was taking this kind of quack medicine that he had picked up in the trenches where he's drinking gun cleaning oil. Goodness. This doesn't do him any good.
总是出现胃痉挛、湿疹之类的毛病，他以为这是癌症，因为他母亲就是死于癌症。没错，他还做了一些极其荒唐的事情。汤姆，关于希特勒，就像你谈论你的韦斯·安德森电影一样，虽然这显然是一个极其黑暗和可怕的故事，但其中却有一些奇怪的喜剧元素。希特勒当时在服用一种他在战壕里弄来的江湖郎中药，他竟然在喝枪支清洁油。天哪，这对他一点好处都没有。
I quote from Kershaw, causes headaches, double vision, dizziness and ringing in his ears. Blimey. What does he think he's curing? I think this is curing. What's it curing? His stomach pains. I mean, if I have a stomach pain. Yeah, that's not how you do it.
我引用克肖的话，这会导致头痛、复视、头晕和耳鸣。天哪。他以为他在治什么病？我想他以为这能治病。治什么？他的胃痛。我是说，如果我有胃痛，我可不会那样做。
I don't drink gun cleaning oil. But anyway, Hitler does. So he thinks he doesn't have much time left. And he thinks, right, come on, let's do this. Four years, the whole thing. We can take the whole thing. And by the whole thing, he doesn't mean Central Europe. He doesn't even really mean Europe.
我可不喝枪支清洁油。但不管怎样，希特勒喝了。所以他认为自己没多少时间了。他想，好吧，来吧，让我们干吧。四年，搞定一切。我们可以拿下整个世界。他说的“整个世界”指的不仅仅是中欧。他甚至不仅仅是指欧洲。
I mean, it's a mad thing to talk about because people don't generally talk about conquering the world unless they're Alexander the Great. Hitler really does think about conquering the world, doesn't he? He thinks Europe first and then the war with the USA and then we're done. But Dominic, he has to take steps. Yes. And you said how he has a dream of greater Germany. And of course, Hitler himself was born in Austria, which is a German speaking part of the Reich.
我的意思是，谈论这个很疯狂，因为除非是亚历山大大帝，否则人们通常不会谈论征服世界。希特勒确实在考虑征服世界，不是吗？他想先拿下欧洲，然后与美国开战，然后我们就大功告成了。但是多米尼克，他必须采取行动。是的。你说过他有一个大德意志的梦想。当然，希特勒本人出生在奥地利，那是帝国讲德语的一部分。
So I guess it's pretty clear by late 1937 what his next target is going to be. Would that be fair? I think that's right. I think the tempest is gathering, Tom, over the skies of Vienna, to use our much-loved metaphor. Yes. So at the end of the Nuremberg Rally that autumn, Hitler says to Goebbels, OK, the next thing is Austria. We're going to resolve that, and we will resolve it with force.
所以我猜到1937年底，他的下一个目标是什么已经很清楚了。这样说公平吗？我想是对的。汤姆，我想用我们最喜欢的比喻来说，维也纳上空风暴正在聚集。是的。所以在那年秋天的纽伦堡集会结束时，希特勒对戈培尔说，好吧，下一件事是奥地利。我们要解决这个问题，而且我们要用武力解决它。
And on the 9th of November, 1937, he calls his military chiefs to the Reich Chancellery and Berlin, and it's there that he is going to lay out his plans. And Tom, we will tell that story, what happens at that meeting, and what happens afterwards in the next episode. But of course, members of the Restless History Club will be able to listen to it right away. Absolutely. So we will see you either straight away if you're a member of the Restless History Club, or we will see you on Thursday for the Anschluss, the German takeover of Austria. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
1937年11月9日，他召集军事首领到柏林的帝国总理府，就在那里，他将阐述他的计划。汤姆，我们将在下一集讲述那个故事，在那次会议上发生了什么，以及之后发生了什么。当然，Restless History Club的成员可以立即收听。绝对的。所以，如果你是Restless History Club的成员，我们会立即见到你，否则我们周四见，届时将讨论德奥合并，即德国对奥地利的接管。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕后，告诉你它是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。